so thanks everyone for attending here uh
very happy and to be here
uh
well we actually already got a great
introduction uh so my name is fenno i'm
a data engineer at enaco enaco is one of
the largest energy suppliers in the
netherlands
and uh today we're going to be talking
about uh specifically estimating solar
panel production
so i'll let my colleague introduce
himself my name is rick
i work as a data scientist for a couple
of years now at neco i have a background
in electroengineering
and then grew a little bit into signal
processing and eventually data science
and i for me enaco's the perfect place
because i have some electricity which is
close to my heart but also some data
science
and actually today's use case will also
be about electricity and data science
so we're going to start with a little
bit of a primer about electricity data
maybe not all of you are familiar but
question who of you has solar panels on
their home
ah that's a good amount okay that's
exciting so
if you have solar panels all you really
care about is production how much do my
solar panels produce right
um
and if your solar panels produce energy
there's two things that can happen
either
it goes directly to whatever you consume
like your washing machine your toaster
your tv whatever is running at that
moment in your house or
if there's an axis it gets redelivered
to the grid this is what we call
re-delivery
in the night you don't have solar
production
you get some delivery from the grid and
that goes to consumption so consumption
can come either from production or from
the grid
your production can go
either back into the grid or directly be
consumed inside of the house
as you might have spotted there is some
green and some red variables in this
picture right so
radiation delivery redelivery are things
that you can measure with your smart
meter well not radiation but we can get
that from the kmi so
um deliver delivery and redeliver is
what goes in and out of your house and
that's what we get from the smart meter
but as a consumer you're maybe more
interested in what is my prediction what
is my concept
so that's a use case we're going to talk
about today if we get the data from your
smart meter redelivery and delivery can
we estimate how much your solar panels
actually were producing
at that day and how much your
self-consumption was so this is a
screenshot
in the right you see from the enaco app
and in the yellow you see your
redelivery so this is what you have been
feeding back into the grid actually this
is a screenshot from my own house
um i don't have a lot of solar panels so
i have don't have like a super huge
redelivery but at the peak it's like
almost 700
watts of re-delivery
and then you see um the green bars and
they're a little bit higher so they are
maybe like
800 900
that is the estimated production of our
solar panels so the difference between
the green and the yellow bars is what i
was consuming myself right so i produced
900 i used 200 i redelivered 700.
this yellow stuff is actual measure data
the green stuff is
stuff that was predicted by a model and
that's the model we're going to talk
about today so this is the huge use case
for estimated production estimated
consumption you can also derive that if
you know one you know the other we also
use that for some of the energy
inside features that are in the in eco
smart meter app
but that's a topic for another day
good
that's the data
that's the use case
but
how do you get smart meter data from
your house
to an app
that's what fennel will talk about
right now yeah let's
talk about the uh the sort of energy
data landscape here so uh your data
starts off being produced by a smart
meter that most people have in their
house
that measures your uh yeah you're
delivering redelivery but this smart
meter is actually operated
not by an aco an eco is like the
supplier
but actually smart meters are operated
by the grid operators
or in dutch they're called net behaviors
these grid operators are responsible for
um maintaining the physical
infrastructure of your
of the electricity network making sure
that it actually keeps working
so these grid operators they also
collect the smart meter data
and of course use it to calculate your
bill
at the end of the year
but there's also sort of this collective
of grid operators that's called energy
data services netherlands and uh they
also collect all this smart meter data
for potentially to be used for other
purposes like what we want to use it for
so there are some like gdpr some uh
privacy um
consequences there so if you want to use
that data for other purposes then just
calculating your bill you actually need
permission also from the customer so we
have to
expressly ask a customer for permission
like are you okay that we
we uh use that data
for other purposes
uh in that case yeah uh that's what
energy data services netherlands also
does is they make sure of that
uh once we have that sort of check from
the customer
they will start sending that data to us
so in this case uh we have this kafka
which is like this messaging streaming
platform that we use to uh to make sure
all this data is available to us
from kafka it then enters our sort of
machine learning slash data science
environment um which in our case is
based on data bricks
uh in data bricks we make a prediction
we predict your your solar usage
from there on it
will make its way eventually back to the
mobile app um
so it's kind of from that moment on a
sort of hands-off for us and
we let all the the front-end mobile app
developers take it from there
so for the rest of the slide we're gonna
focus on uh
on this data science environment so you
continue
thanks
so let's dive a little bit deeper and
look into our data science flow
basically what we depicted here is
how we do predictions
and how we do training of the model so
on the top you see
your day-to-day prediction flow so every
day data comes in we need to make a
prediction of solar production in this
case but also there's many other use
cases
so you have your incoming data then
there's some pre-processing steps and
then you have
the distributed predictions we'll get
into that later
but for now let's focus first on the
on the bottom half so with the
historical data
you can train the model
um and finally we put that model in some
place that can also be used
um later on in the predictions this
seems a little bit trivial now but it's
important to have this flow in your mind
when we dive into each of the subtopics
so
let's talk about the bottom flow the
experimentation making a model
and getting it to run so the input data
this is basically a summary of what you
already saw also on
the very first slide
the input data that we have is delivery
data
redelivery data and global radiation
data those are the three
green things you saw on the first slide
there are each 96 data points because we
get them at 15 minutes intervals and
there's 15
there's 96 50 minute intervals in one
day
and we do a prediction on a day by day
basis
then the output what do we want to get
that's basically the green bar that you
saw in the first picture is for the full
day how much did they produce for every
50 minute interval
finally we have our input and our output
data but we need some label data right
every machine learning start with what
labels can i get what quality data can i
get
and the good thing is that eneko also
offers a smart thermostat
which also delivers energy inside so
it's also connected to your electricity
and gas meter inside of the house
and this one can get real-time insights
in a lot better resolution than we can
get
the long route phenox plates from the
smart meters grid operators all that
kind of stuff
and withdrawn also comes a module that
will actually measure what are your
solar panels producing and what is a
household consuming so basically there
we have all the also all the red parts
so we can use that data re-sample it to
the same 15-minute interval
and then we have our training data
good now fennel will
explain
this one's on you right this is my side
okay sorry
um
good if we think about training the
model
we need to think about the model and
this is the model that we eventually
settled on we
we began with a lot more complex
architecture but then figured
maybe you can simply simplify it
make it a little bit sparser so if
you're familiar with neural network and
you have done some image recognition
actually this is pretty similar so what
usually what you have
we start with our three times 96 inputs
which i explained on the previous slide
and then we have a convolution stat and
the convolution step is there to
recognize patterns maybe like the sum
going up or the sun going down
um
just to see the temp temporal
correlation in the data
then we flatten everything and then
there's a layer of fully connected steps
and
in the end
that's where the model really
you hopefully learns all the stuff that
you wanted to learn and then finally we
also have a convolution step in the
output
to again kind of like scale up the model
have a time series output and also make
sure that the output is a little bit
self-correlated as well so you get a
nice smooth
output
in your curve
yeah
so
that architecture uh yeah it works quite
well uh
but we ran into sort of well let's say
this this classic kind of deep learning
uh problem is that it just takes a while
and in our case the issue especially is
we have a lot of data
we have a lot of uh
yeah a little fine fine grain data over
a long period of time from both
customers and we kind of want to use all
of this data of course because
that's a really a nice problem to have
but it just takes a while to train the
model so um
the obvious like an answer this also
means that iterating uh becomes a bit
slower right you want to try some some
hyper parameter tuning and try some
stuff out maybe remove a layer or
add a layer or something but
you have to wait a few hours so that's
kind of uh unfortunate so
the uh we could try experimenting with
less data of course but that's also a
bit unsatisfying
so of course we start thinking okay can
we just use multiple gpus right we have
this sort of cloud environment we can
rent gpus from from the cloud so uh
let's just throw more power at the
problem and that leads into this uh in
this concept called distributed deep
learning that i want to spend like it's
a quick minute introducing like um what
do i mean with distributed deep learning
because it's i would say it's quite a
relevant sort of uh topic these days
right like our model is sort of
relatively small i would say in the
grand scheme of things compared to like
some tech giants out there
but there are
in general there's a large need to have
to be able to use more gpus to be able
to um
speed up machine learning deep learning
like training so there's kind of two
main methods i would say of this should
distribute deep learning to how you're
going to split up the problem across
multiple gpus um one of those
is what's called
model um parallelism so that's where you
want to split up your model across
different gpus so if you have let's say
you have a model with 10 layers but one
way to split up that model would be to
have for example five gpus and then each
gpu is going to
have contained two the parameters of two
layers
and
that
it works really well for very large
models if you have huge models with
billions of parameters uh that's i mean
it almost becomes necessary right
because one
because the entire model wouldn't even
fit on a single gpu
um so that's that model parallelism is
also what's what's used by you hear
these models in the news about gp3 with
hundreds of billions of parameters
that's what they use
but we actually kind of have a little
bit of an opposite problem we don't have
a very large model uh when you just look
at the number of parameters
but we have a lot of data so we actually
kind of want to use maybe a bit more of
a simpler parallelism method
where we just have the model on a single
gpu but we want to just process the data
faster so
that's where
that's where the second sort of way of
distributive learning comes in that's
called data parallelism
so our solution is to use this um to use
the open source python packets it's
called horrorvault it was developed by
uber
and this is sort of a python package
that makes it possible for you to do
data parallelism in i would say quite a
straightforward way
um
so the way that works is let's say you
are going to train an epoch of your your
um your model well instead of just
taking one
batch of data and giving it to your gpu
it essentially takes four batches of
data at the same time so it will take
four batches of data or well four is
variable right you could use eight or
sixteen so um if you use eight gpus it
will take eight batches of data
distribute it out to your eight gpus and
then they all do like
an epoch
at the same time and then at the end of
that epoch you are going to like sum all
the gradients together so effectively
what you are doing is you're kind of
increasing your bet size
if you normally use a bed size 128 well
if you have eight gpus and you give each
of those eight gpus uh the same bets
then you are
your bed size effectively becomes 1024
and what that also means
um
i'm not going to go too deep into the
math here but if you uh increase your
bet size in general that means you can
also
increase your learning rate so
if you want the same convergence
properties on your model and you
increase the bet size by a certain
amount you can also increase the
learning rate by that same amount so
and of course if you increase the
learning rate by a lot that usually
means your model is going to converge a
bit quick quite a bit quicker as well
so this ends up working really nicely
and speeding it up quite a lot
um
so one sort of characteristic about
volvo volt is this sort of what's called
ring formation so there's an interesting
problem is how do you actually share
these gradients
uh sort of a classical maybe old-school
solution to this would be to have some
kind of parameter server to have some
kind of central server that just stores
all the parameters all the gradients for
all the for all the individual um
nodes and then shares them around but
that kind of adds a lot of overhead so
this is sort of the characteristic way
that hov does things is it uses this
kind of ring formation where uh where
every sort of node only needs to
communicate with one other node
and that actually causes it to well
basically make the epochs almost exactly
the same time than they would have
except you now process
double the bet size or quadruple or
octuple depending on however many gpus
you want to use
so
um
i want to give a code sample because uh
for those of you that may be interested
uh
uh
i think it's good to give an example of
how does this actually work so here's
sort of a i would say fairly minimal
example of this is actually basically
taken also from our code except i
removed some a lot of unnecessary
details uh so on the first line we have
this uh oh i would say standard pi torch
optimizer
the model's not defined here but trust
me there's a model behind there
and um
another node is volvo does also work
with tensorflow and cables
but in our case we use uh by torch and
the only change we make to the regular
like bartwortz model is we change the
learning rate here so you can see we we
multiply this learning rate with volvo
dot size and what that size that's a
parameter that that
contains like the number of nodes
and like i just explained
because we are
using a much bigger bet size it's also
is a good idea to also basically
increase our learning rate accordingly
then the second step here is to create
this whole optimizer and it's almost i
i don't want to exaggerate but it's
almost kind of like magic in the sense
that it's uh it will do a lot of stuff
like behind the scenes and uh this will
drop to all the gradient summing all
behind the scenes and it kind of just
works um there's one more thing you need
to do
if you think about it
uh
about the like initialization of the of
the models right if you have a gpus and
you want to
initialize the model you need to make
sure they're all initialized with the
exact same random state because if they
have a different random state then the
gradients are going to be incomparable
you you are not going to be able to um
to add the gradients together so we need
to have this like sort of what's called
here broadcast parameter step where we
are going to like make sure they all
have the same initial random state and
then after that there is a
um yeah sort of
standard pi torch training loop here uh
it's a bit simplified but you can sort
of see it's a
straightforward part of the training
loop the only change here is that we
replaced like the python optimizer with
the like horror fault optimizer object
but otherwise
essentially
if you sort of
have a little bit of time you can sort
of
without too much effort adapt an
existing like deep learning method uh
model into a
uh into a whole model the
most difficult thing i would say is
actually finding a computer with like
four or eight gpus that's quite
difficult these days
so now we have our model
and i think i'm going to hand it over
and see what we do then after we have
trained our model
yes thanks so if you think back to the
experimentation flow now we showed you
what our model is like how we train it
but
as with all data scientists there's a
lot of bookkeeping to do right you want
experiments you want to
try a different layer adding it trying
some hyper brand new tuning of course we
also tried some other models
and that's why i want to explain a
little bit about the ammo flow setup
mflow is an open source
package basically for
keeping track of all machine lear
machine learning related attacks
um
and basically we use it for
three things
first of all
as i just explained you just want to do
different experiment
and if you do this in a notebook
environment it's
able to kind of like track everything
that you do but also keep a version
history using git under the hood of what
your notebook was like at the time so
you can go back at any time
um
there's also an element of
actually preserving the model that you
have trained
using a pickle
um
so you take the model you also lock this
as
as an artifact and you can retrieve it
then later to also render model again
um
actually with the pickling
we ran into some other issues as well
and that's what our talk this afternoon
together with grenade will be about
so if you want to learn more about
pickling stay tuned for the that part
and finally there's also a part where
you can select which model you want to
have live
so
this is a very minimal code example but
just to show that it's relatively low
effort to put it in your code loop so
in python you just get your training
data
and in the end you have your drain
gears model
and
in python you have this nice width block
which makes the context you also use it
if you open a file and basically it
starts something then you do your code
and then it stops something again so
this keeps track of it makes a new
run
and then now we're using the auto logger
but you can log any parameters and
metrics that you want which is a bit of
an upside than a downside because you
can do everything you like but then you
also need to do it yourself
so this is what some of the different
runs look like right it looks a little
bit messy but that is typically what
machine learning
is like
in my view right even if you work
structured sometimes it fails sometimes
you try some different runs and that's
something you see in like the red and
green things like some of them
failed and some of them are successful
but we also keep track of some of the
parameters like our loss or like how
complex was the model and in the end we
can use this overview to see okay which
model has the best trade-off between
uh
test performance and how complex the
model it was or how long it took to
train
um
[Music]
and then finally you can put this model
into production
which is basically you just take one of
the entries that you saw from the
previous slide and you just
apply a text say hey this is now
prediction so then if you go back to
your flow
this is the final part like the model
registry
and then if you do your predictions you
can say hey i want a model that has
stack production
uh can you please give it to me and then
it can be used
um for the prediction in that flow
yeah
uh
yeah well can you go back
for the uh yeah so um
uh basically you see here the bottom uh
sort of pipeline um uses well it doesn't
use much like spark or any spark
because well we kind of uh
uh want to train on like one instance
with a lot of gpus mostly uh training a
deep learning model is actually like can
be a little bit difficult to parallelize
because if you think about training a
deep learning model is like incredibly
sort of
all these parameters are like dependent
on each other right we want to share all
these gradients around uh and all these
parameters are dependent on each other
so it's actually a little bit difficult
to to really parallelize
a deep learning model
like very easily
but when we when it comes to prediction
it actually sort of becomes well a lot
easier uh because predictions can be
made essentially independently of each
other we have our model that saves in ml
flow
we can then make predictions on
essentially as many instances as we want
at the same time uh so that's where we
can sort of easily bring in uh spark
um
so yeah can you uh continue so uh
there's a few sort of considerations to
be made there one is sort of cost
right we training our model is kind of
done on gpu we don't really have uh
a choice there because training a model
on a cpu is not really a feasible but
actually prediction predicting is kind
of fine right it takes a little bit
longer on on the cpu but it's it's not
that bad
so
and we and of course we can save quite a
bit of money because gpus are a bit
expensive these days
um
so we we change our prediction to cpu
instead
however we still have sort of an issue
with uh with prediction for the volume
so uh we have a lot of predictions to be
made
every day we sort of make the prediction
for like the last day uh so like i
explained the way to parallelize this is
sort of by splitting it up uh um using
spark we can use for instance 16 workers
to do prediction uh 16 times at the same
time and i think the reason why we use
16 is because it's a nice sort of power
of two
so it's an aesthetically nice number
uh so that's that's that part of the
puzzle
uh yeah and then so like i explained i
think the very beginning once those
predictions are made they're then sent
off they're sort of out of our hands
send off to like the mobile app
development team and uh they end up sort
of back in the like the mine enaco app
so uh
yeah i would say to anyone here that's
uh an encore customer i saw a lot of
people had solar panels so uh i would
say give give permission uh that's great
because you get some insights and also
we get more data to work with as well
so
and then you can see these kinds of
screenshots as well
yes
i want also to end the presentation with
thanking ofr team members of course we
are presenting this we're
shining uh with the use case but i'm not
a mobile app developer
and also there's a lot of data science
data engineer software engineering work
that
went into this so uh
yes thanks to everybody that makes it
work and
i think this was the end of our
presentation
yeah
[Applause]
thank you and
questions so i'm gonna start from here
um yeah my question would be like
regarding the architecture that you have
so since you are mostly working with
let's say time series kind of data
why didn't you consider some lstm
based architecture for your model
training or
corn palestinian kind
um good question i don't know
i think i think we did at some point
there was a lot of experimentation that
went through into this also by other
people than us but maybe if anyone want
to say well i think i think i that has
been tried but it's uh it's the kind of
thing you know uh
experimentation can be a bit messy so uh
i don't know exactly how those
experiments went but i think it's just
sort of what ended up working uh the
best for us was this sort of i would say
relatively sort of simple kind of model
uh ended up just giving a better
performance than uh
then like a more complex kind of lcm
model
yeah lsteam can be simple as well learn
based on the kind of architecture that
uh second question would be like you
told
using this parallel architecture you
managed to train faster because you had
like much
higher learning rate
and it converts faster so did you had
any
any issue with like sub optimal solution
or
because it converts too fast maybe
didn't reach the optimal solution and
how did you tackle that problem
like is it like it could be
theoretically possible that it converges
slower because of you have or that it
doesn't converge as well because of the
higher learning rate you mean or yeah
exactly it might not be optimal as well
right it's stuck into a local minima uh
yeah i think that's
that's probably possible but uh
i
don't think that's the problem we had
like we also had a lot of data to work
with so uh
uh
yeah that's not something that we ran
into so you didn't have an issue with
overfitting or anything else
well not sure if we overfitted in
general but uh
well
i
did wow
thank you for your a great talk i had a
lot of fun uh watching
um i i used myself the the built-in uh
parallelism engine in tensorflow so why
not use that one instead
i think the
[Music]
we use spark for a lot of
experimentation also for loading in the
data and harvard also has the option to
use spark for parallelism and and we
didn't end uh abusing that
um but for us that was a nice thing to
try out so that
we also had the potential to use spark j
another model was trained on pipe swords
i'm actually i'm not sure if python also
probably also has parallelism methods
but
it's a quick comment about that yeah no
no i i like it anyway because i didn't
know about the library now i do so
thanks
so you mentioned a little bit about the
use case um but i i don't get it yet
like what value does it have to an echo
to on to be able to predict this why not
just predict the uh the the stuff that
is
the flavoring
so you're asking what is the value in
seeing the produced solar exactly i
think
it's not necessarily value to an eco but
value to the end customers i think a lot
of people want to see
how much how well their solar panels are
performing right if you have like a 1200
watt peak
installation and then it's a sunny day
you want to see did i make my 1200 watt
peak but if you were consuming 400 watts
you only see 800 watts of re-delivery
so
there's a bit of a blind spot in what is
your self-consumption and what do you
really deliver back to the grid so to
get insight in what you're really using
that's why we estimate the produced
solar power but you could prevent the
whole thing by by just having some piece
of hardware that registers the the
production right yes yes so for the
smart thermostat we have a piece of
hardware that measures that but you need
to go into your metering cabinet then
take out some wires and put in this
module back
the nice thing about the enaco app
is that it's using smart metering data
which already gets sent to the grid
operator so all you have to do is
install the app get permission
and be an eco customer of course but
it's like completely hardware free in
that we're using a heart rate that
already exists
cool thanks yeah that clarifies
um maybe instead of the the hardware
solution did you consider just asking
the users how many single panels do you
have and maybe if you know what's the
the peak production
that they achieve and include that
information in your
prediction in training
so the question is can we ask users how
many solar panels do you have
to enhance
this
prediction yeah it seems like relevant
information and if you can just get it
from the customer who's interested in
this makes it a lot simpler
mm-hmm
[Music]
for this particular use case i don't
think it is as
it will be asked now in the smart
thermostat app
it's an interesting point i don't think
we do it yet
i do think the model should be able to
get most of it because it if you kind of
like have a baseline electricity
consumption on a sunny day you're
supposed to come close to your max
and then maybe once in a day you get
close to like a really power and if you
have something that's always on
you should always always
also be able to see that during the
night like what is your base load
consumption
but i think it's a good question it
would help if you ask how many solar
panels are there and i think that's
that's maybe one of the tricky parts
also now of course we have one model
that will predict for all the users and
of course it has seen a lot of users so
it can generalize also a little bit
but every household can also have his
particular things right there might be a
household that has a tree and then in
the morning it doesn't have any
prediction because there's shade on the
house so
um
i think there's more
specialization things that we could do
to make it better for individual
households
thank you
thanks great talk thank you very much um
just simple question what is the next
thing you guys are going to do now that
you've practiced
um
well one other thing uh
one other thing that we are
one other use case that's already out
there that i think is also interesting
to mention we also have a service where
from the electricity signals you can
detect which appliances are running if
you see like a
bump that might be a washing machine or
a dryer and in the night you can see the
fridge turn on and on so we also have
the service that
breaks it down
electricity and actually that bare
weight gun electricity bill breakdown
was also a reason to make this because
now we can also use the true consumption
for that
and one other thing that we're keen on
is
having something that's more involved
also with the user so
can we set some goals like uh how much
would you like to save or
you're doing like this but you want to
go there can we help you with that or
get some smart tips so i think this is a
great insight for the user but we're
also thinking about how can we make it
more interactive and really
stimulate people to go green so to see
yeah cool this is like the previous
question then right like what's the
usefulness of having this so you want to
enable your users to do more or less or
have more insights thank you
hi
awesome model definitely great work so
my question is similar to his question
about the business case on this
i mean gpus are expensive you guys are
probably burning through maybe like 100k
a month or something if you re-trade a
model
um this is what we we're doing
um how do you justify this to the
pending pinching managers who are saying
okay but how does this add value to my
company so it definitely has value to
your customers yes but how does that
value to the company because
they're paying the bill for the gpu yes
that's a good question and i think
that's always
an ongoing discussion
because i think
part of the values i think in
building a
better relation with your customer right
if you have this great insight you're
not maybe not going to change to
customers
like
a different energy supplier next year so
that's part of it
but we also find that it's very hard to
quantify
um and i think another thing could be
that you can make smarter suggestions
for
improvements to your house
if we
uh so this is the case for people with
solar panels but for people that don't
have solar panels there's also a similar
kind of simulation that says hey you
don't have solar panels but you could
make this much if you would have solar
panels
so have you thought about offering this
surface to your energy futures traders
that say okay on aggregate we're
probably going to have to produce more
energy because the weather forecast for
the next two days is
a low end low solar panel so we're gonna
have to buy more energy from the grid
because that's like a direct benefit for
the business case from having a solar
prediction model um
so you're about about more future
predictions and like grid balancing uh
discounts yeah i'm interested training
and i think
we we basically we kind of already do
that we we already share some sort of
but especially on the usage side on like
how much customer how much xpc users use
that's a very interesting information
for
futures i agree so we we actually
already do some of that not as much as
we would like but some of that already
yeah
you